the media is gathered security around
the courthouse is being ramped up and
the former president is due to be
indicted on the most serious charges yet
brought against him
one of his lawyers says the defense
rejects a trial date envisioned by the
prosecution to take president Trump to
trial in 90 days of course is absurd the
question is why do they want to do that
if you want to seek Justice then you
need to offer Mr president president
Trump an opportunity to get a hold of
all the evidence the federal judge who
was chosen at random to hear the case is
jamaican-born Tanya chitkin she was
appointed by Obama in 2014 she's
presided over dozens of prosecutions
relating to the attack on the capital on
January the 6th 2021 which she is
described in one judgment as a violent
attempt to overthrow the government and
it nearly succeeded
the judge also presided over an action
brought by Donald Trump in November 2021
to prevent the White House from handing
over documents to a house select
committee she rejected the application
saying on that occasion the president is
not a king and the plaintiff is not the
president
in the conspiracy charges the
prosecution outlines the extent to which
Donald Trump attempted to persuade his
then vice president to refuse to certify
the vote does one of what the indictment
says is a series of Criminal Acts
and in relation to Trump's actions
leading up to and on January the 6th
Mike Pence issued his strongest
criticism yet and then on that day
president Trump asked me to put him over
the Constitution but I chose the
Constitution and I always will
and I I
really do believe that uh Anyone who
puts himself over the Constitution
should never be president of the United
States
and anyone who asks someone else to put
themselves over the Constitution should
never be president of the United States
again
the former president's response was
scathing in a lengthy message on his
social media Donald Trump says off Pence
he didn't fight against election fraud
which we will now be easily able to
prove based on the most recent fake
indictment and information which will
have to be made available to us finally
a really big deal the VP had power that
Mike didn't understand
more than a thousand people are being
convicted on charges related to actions
stemming from this baseless claim of
election fraud
some sentenced to prison terms of up to
18 years
the charges are similar to those brought
against Donald Trump
Mike Hannah aljazeera Washington
well Heidi Joe Castro is at the
courthouse in Washington D.C where Trump
is expected to appear
the former president will be arrested
and arraigned on Thursday he's expected
to come in person to the D.C Federal
Courthouse behind me which is just a
stone's throw away from the U.S Capitol
that was stormed by his supporters on
January 6. Trump will likely not be
handcuffed or have to take a mug shot he
wasn't made to in either of the two
previous indictments security here will
be tight though it's hard to predict how
many protesters or supporters may turn
up a Magistrate Judge will make sure
that Trump understands the charges he
faces and then will likely allow him to
enter a plea and Trump says he will
plead not guilty then this case will be
handed to judge Tanya chudkin who will
set the trial date no one knows if it's
possible to complete a trial before the
next presidential election in November
of next year and Trump has vowed to
continue his candidacy for president no
matter the outcome Heidi Joe Castro Al
Jazeera Washington
well Glenn Carl is a former National
Intelligence official he joins us by
Skype from Boston thank you very much
for being on Al Jazeera Now assistant 24
hours until Trump is due to be in that
courthouse in Washington D.C not far
from the capital what sort of security
concerns are there and and what do you
think should be put in place to try and
deal with potentially thousands of trump
supporters and uh protesters uh that are
likely to to head to the courthouse
well the specific threats if there be
any of course uh you and I don't know
them but from what we uh what I have
known for for literally decades is that
every year the National Security
establishment the FBI the CIA and so on
have to by law assess
um and rank the threats to the United
States and the number one threat from
back uh
earliest in my career which goes back
decades now was and Remains the domestic
uh white supremacist uh supremacist uh
nationalists militias they are armed and
they are hostile to the federal
government and as we have seen they are
have been involved in various plots to
overthrow it a number of them now are in
are in jail for their participation and
involvement in the Insurrection on
January 6th but the organizations remain
so that's the number one threat and the
way one authorities have to try to stop
it is you try to penetrate them that was
the job of my colleagues and then the
law enforcement
authorities the police and so on will
set up various perimeters in case of
unrest
I suspect there might be less risk for
now because numbers of them are in jail
and are being prosecuted for their
involvement on January 6th and that
might have a salutatory effect on their
willingness to take a risk again just in
the in the wake of January the sixth
we're just watching pictures uh here
from from that day what lessons have
been learned from what was a you know
failure from a security perspective what
can be learned from from that and what
do you think will be implemented here uh
when Trump goes to court this time but
but also in the months ahead
well there have been fingers pointed
frankly by the right by the Republicans
on the
incompetence of the response of the law
enforcement and security authorities
during the January 6th Insurrection
that's really a misleading
finger-pointing and uh putting the blame
where it shouldn't lie because it was
three hours
after the Insurrection began before any
orders were given for the law
enforcement authorities at the city or
the federal level to take any action so
since you had participants frankly which
will be proven in the court of law
perhaps
inside the government in aiding and
abetting of the Insurrection the law
enforcement didn't act but if they are
properly LED and instructed to uphold
their obligations in their Oaths then
they will act to keep a crowd from
becoming unruly or from penetrating the
courthouse
you said before that uh white supremacy
is the number one a national security
threat can you just give us specifics
about how security Personnel will deal
with them in particular
well the aspect of the the issue that I
am most familiar with is obtaining
information about their plans and
intentions now as a CIA officer I had
nothing to do by law with any domestic
issue except you know if there were a
foreign aspect to it and then I would
work with the or my colleagues with the
FBI but the FBI has the lead on this and
their job is similar to what mine was
overseas and that is to penetrate any
and learn its plans and intentions with
respect to hostile act or an illegal act
against the United States so that's the
first step what we all see are the
uniformed Personnel who will establish
these perimeters and so on they may res
information from the FBI that a certain
individual
is intended to do something and and then
then the detention is is possible if
there are there's probable cause but but
first plans and attentions by the FBI
and then second measures to counter any
physical act okay we're going to have to
leave it there but thank you so much for
your time and your Insight that's Glenn
Carl former National Intelligence
official thank you